welcome to Hannity and this is a Fox
News Alert at this hour
nutty Jerry Nadler circus his ship show
is now still ongoing we're gonna monitor
this raid throughout the hour plus
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
he will join us he will tell us well if
they do impeach the president what will
happen in the Senate important
information but tonight we start on
November the 8th 2016 62 million
Americans you we the American people you
shocked the world you voted for Donald
Trump he won a whopping 300 for
electoral votes he carried over 30
states and now Democrats are officially
trying to flush that free and fair
election down the toilet based on zero
high crimes zero misdemeanors and zero
counts of bribery and zero counts of
treason treason this is what we've
gotten for three long years just two
made-up baseless week fact list charges
that would never be allowed in a court
of law this charade boils down to one
thing and one thing only that is the
left liberals Democrats socialists and
their media mob friends they think that
they know better than we the people that
voted for this president now they look
down their noses at us fine they have
contempt for our values our views and
our life and a way of life they hate us
and they hate our choice for president
so for three years three long years they
have desperately tried to undo an
election and impeach Donald Trump don't
take my word for it just listen to their
dear fearless leader
speaker Pelosi earlier this week this is
quite revealing take a look one of the
biggest criticisms of the process has
been the speed at which the House
Democrats are moving if this is but
seriously though it seriously it's been
going on for 22 months okay
and a half years actually a two and a
half years but since he got their rare
moment of truth
even for Pelosi now first way back in
January 2017
it was the Russia Russia Russia hoax and
coordination with a corrupt deceitful
propaganda state-run Democratic
Socialist TV mob and the media Democrats
have lied over and over and over again
about Trump and Russia and collusion the
only collusion was the dirty Russian
dossier that Hillary paid for then you
got the compromised corrupt congenital
liar Adam Schiff said he had ample and
significant evidence of collusion and we
had the shift' show now the nutty Nadler
shift show by the way he's now running
his own full shift show and he said
there was collusion in plain sight
remember or Eric's wall well oh he did
great in his run for the presidency
saying the president acts on Russia's
behalf well maybe it was Hillary bought
the Russian dossier
he got NBC News chief conspiracy
theorists he got area 51 Roswell Rachel
Maddow calling Trump a Russian up Tom
Brokaw speak up are you proud of this
they were all lying through their teeth
three years lies misinformation
propaganda they have smear slander
besmirch Minh this is who they are this
is what they do four separate
investigations found zero evidence of
trump Russia collusion none zip a huge
blow to the Democrats plan to impeach
the president they thought Muller would
get them over the finish line so instead
of apologizing for the years of lying to
the country and putting the country
through hell well they just simply move
on to Plan B let's make up a new
conspiracy theory
we'll call the Ukrainian hoax and now
the election fast approaching Democrats
they don't have any time to waste now
they can't rely on the American people
to do their bidding take a look we
cannot rely on an election to solve our
problems when the president threatens
the very integrity of that election so
with a heavy heart of clearing my duty
to our country I support these articles
of impeachment
I urge my colleagues to support them as
well all right despite his heavy heavy
heavy or nutty heart of Nadler while
he's now racing to get this thing across
the finish line and of course Pelosi
announced that a vote will take place
next week for the past 10 straight hours
again today Democrats in the House
Judiciary Committee they've been holding
an all-day marathon we got to get it
done before Christmas hearing in case
you missed it you learned absolutely
nothing new all day no new facts
presented no evidence introduced no
witnesses called there's only been one
fact witness everyone else hearsay or
opinion instead we hear from a bunch of
Democratic lawmakers totally divorced
from reality living in the land of rage
and hate and psychosis against Trump one
congressman comparing the impeachment
charade actually to the civil rights and
suffrage movements while they think a
lot of themselves take a look some will
cynically argue that the impeachment of
this president will further divide an
already fractured Union slavery once
divided the nation but emancipator's
rose up to clarify that all men are
created equally suffrage once divided
the nation but women rolls up to clarify
that all voices must be heard in our
democracy Jim Crow once divided the
nation but civil rights champions rose
up to clarify that all are entitled to
equal protection under the law and all
lies and all conspiracy theories have to
be peddled and as per usual Democrats
are clearly more interested in hyping up
their own witch trial than actually
getting to any truth or real justice
because the truth is not good for the
Democratic Party take a look
when this amendment strikes the
reference to Joe Biden as the center of
the proposed investigation and replaces
it with the true topic of the
investigation Maurice MA and Hunter
Biden Hertz called the Prescott Police
Department and officers filed a
narcotics offense report listing items
seized in the car including a past
plastic bag containing white powder
substance a secret service business card
credit cards and hunter Biden's driver's
license it's a little hard to believe
that burr yzma hired hunter Biden to
resolve their international disputes
when he could not resolve his own
dispute with Hertz rental car overly
believed in cocaine and a crack pipe in
the car congressman Matt Gaetz
advocating for an amendment to the
articles of impeachment that would
actually include language about hunter
Biden and yeah a zero experience and the
millions he's paid well it's pretty
simple as a quid and a pro and a quo by
Joe and hunter zero experience hunter of
course was selling his access to his
father that's the real evidence of real
abuse of power which they ignore that
gates amendment was ultimately defeated
along party lines along with several
other amendments the American people we
know what's going on here
this is nothing but a partisan circus to
undo an election President Trump will
never be convicted in the Senate senator
Graham will dismiss and Senator
McConnell will dismiss these phony
charges and all the other Republican
senators look at your screen look at
these 31 Democrats from those districts
that President Trump carried in 2016 see
Nancy Pelosi she is now making all of
those lawmakers walk the plank for
nothing
sacrificing those seats to placate a
radical extreme socialist base and now
some of these lawmakers are starting a
waffle and buckle under the pressure
take a look are you ready to vote for
them know what I'm gonna do right now is
do what I was always trying to do as a
CIA officer which is sit by myself with
the full body of information the
question going forward will be are these
lawmakers going to do Pelosi's bidding
or the way they actually represent the
people that hired them